anyways we just got back from our walk
and this is part of a routine every day
so they're just waiting now this is the
first time I show them affection it's
like feeding them the biggest change in
my life has been way of like actually
looking at life this is the best part of
my day you know wasn't a completely
different place in my head
[Music]
carmine Jackie went berserk on each
other
Jackie had grabbed Carmine's neck and
twisted and carmine was gasping for air
he almost popped Carmine's eyeball out
there went sit down the reason why we
kill ourselves throughout a regular
business day was to be able to come home
and have that moment with your dogs you
know I just I don't want them to live in
crates anymore cuz that's you know I
feel horrible I want my life back to
normal you hear what's happening outside
swore it made sense to me to him by
Rebecca and Daniel to the dog psychology
center so I can introduce them to my
pack
Daniel is making a huge mistake of
dividing the pack by favoring one of
them you can't say this is my dog once
you're in front of a pack of dogs
they're all part of your pack that is a
healthy dog ownership this whole problem
was us they come with you for two
seconds I mean it's almost like they
don't even have aggression product but
it's some things you guys have to let go
in order for them to be real in your
house
[Music]
Daniel and Rebecca Diaz own two
businesses in Southern California they
wanted to bring their three dogs to work
every day the only bad thing is they
created chaos and frighten their
employees I'm gonna be honest I'm
terrified of Jack so I'm terrified
[Music]
that's chewy that's not jack chewy
created a problem you know the favorite
guy the baby of the house was creating
the chaos he was the instigator they
want you to send to me is the one who's
making the problem hey I think the
biggest change is that we have our
reward now that we didn't have before so
it's easier to get through the day
because you know you're not gonna go
home to a fight you guys so at work you
have more energy I guess because you're
not draining it at home too so you have
to let him know you guys are not the one
controlling this offices us all the
humans so no matter where they are
everybody should correct him that's
right yeah when Caesar came to show us
how we needed to work with these dogs
and the idea behind it maybe there's an
outlook on life it gave me a different
outlook and in a different nature about
myself